Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for May 3rd,
2015 what's going on?
How's it going?
How fucking I uh,
um,
I'm fucking wiped out.
The tour is over.
Michael Corleone.
Godfather part two.
Oh VA.
Um,
the summer wind,
it came blowing in from a cross that see?
So I feel like right now because it's over and the lingo adapt to touch your
hair and motherfucking walk with me all summer long photo,
we sang a song and then we did some other shared by Dubai.
They're baggy booboo.
Oh freckles is going back to his fucking house
is fucking house with the leaky roof.
Daddy had to repair Bible,
verbal VT Boob,
those fucking conch,
those contract and con.
Oh Jesus.
I still have one more bill with them.
They,
it goes on and on.
Yeah.
So Call Adam Carolla.
He'll kick their ass.
But then you'll look like a SAP on TV buddy buddy too.
Cause you're the Douche bag that had the call Adam Carolla.
Cause you're not big enough of a man to tell a contract to go fuck himself.
Um,
yeah,
Jesus Christ.
Anyways.
Okay.
I'm fucking wiped out.
All right.
I don't know what you want from me this week,
but this is the best it's going to get.
All right.
This is going to be majors nice and fucking relaxed.
Um,
I am right now,
I am in a,
I don't even know where I am.
I think I'm in Columbia,
Indiana.
I know what you're thinking.
Bill.
What the fuck are you doing there?
That wasn't on the tour,
that wasn't on your southern tour,
you know,
saw the tour,
Savannah,
Georgia,
Knoxville,
Tennessee,
Chattanooga,
Memphis,
Tennessee,
Sri,
fort,
Louisiana,
New Orleans,
Huntsville,
Alabama,
Jackson,
Ms Cfe,
mobile,
Alabama.
Spend a night in Chattanooga,
Tennessee,
uh,
off the legs and Tin Kentucky over the Evansville,
Indiana.
Um,
there was nothing on there that,
that said that you were going to Columbus,
Indiana.
Well,
I mean,
I ended up here because yesterday I went to the,
uh,
to the Kentucky Derby.
Uh,
me,
Paul Versey,
Jason Law head,
and his dad,
the hall of Fame Basketball Coach Jim law had,
we all went to the game,
the game.
We went to the Derby man.
What a fucking great time.
I,
I'm highly suggest going that dressing like a jackass.
Like everybody does.
Big stupid hats.
Bow ties.
The women there.
Good Lord.
Uh,
there's some fucking Philly
beautiful women,
beautiful women.
I'll tell you it deaf.
They the fucking women.
They'll fucking
dude,
they were crushing it right up until the early fifties of talent.
Some fucking decades.
Decades of fucking Derby Williams.
Winter's walking around the fucking the,
uh,
the grand stand area.
Um,
we had great seats and a right a little bit past the finish line.
We just had the best time,
you know,
it was fucked up was that they sold them,
but I don't even know how to get into this man.
They,
they was selling like standing room only seats are right.
So we paid through the fucking knows to sit in a box,
right?
Like we donate it to a presidential campaign.
We were sitting right at the God damn finish line a little past it,
a little past whatever.
Don't break my balls.
Come on.
You can see the horses we were,
we were at.
You could actually see them start of the race ran right by us.
Then they went around the first turn and then they kind of disappeared behind a
some of these corporate tents in the sea of fucking sunburn humanity that was
standing just standing on the inside grass,
which I don't know why you would do that.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
why?
Why wouldn't you stay at home and just watch it on TV and not sit there like a
bunch of fucking refugees in a tent city that had no tent for you?
You know,
you might as well have watched that.
Watch a police horse gallop by after a crack crackhead underneath the fucking
overpass as far as I'm concerned.
All right.
In fields,
seats are for fucking animals.
All right?
Unless you're young,
you don't have any fucking money.
All right?
You have a television.
It's on TV for fucking free.
Why are you going to stand there?
Although I would do it,
I do it a NASCAR race.
I do that in a second.
I'd be on the infield because you know,
first of all,
what I like about being on the Infield,
it's the fucking inertia.
When those fucking cars wipe out usually takes them to the outside wall.
And I know sometimes the bang off the outside wall and they go to the inside,
but at least they hit the wall and they're starting to slow down.
You know what I mean?
And you know,
every once in a while a tire flies off and somebody loses a head of two.
But that's the price you pay for getting to sit on your fucking cooler in the
middle of the goddamn track.
I actually had one of the best times I ever had and went to the Indy 500 and
like 1995 and most of you were like eight years old.
And uh,
we sat on the inside of one of the turns,
brought in this giant fucking cooler and me and my two buddies just got
obliterated.
You know,
watching the fucking go to the buy.
It's hilarious.
You don't see anything,
you just sit in the inside turns and you just hear,
Oh,
Ooh,
oh my voice is fucked up.
Well,
I tell you what,
here,
you just see him go by,
right?
And every once in a while somebody would hit the wall in front of you.
Like,
oh my God,
was she an accident?
But you forgot they're going like 200 something miles an hour.
So they hit the wall in front of you and then just go.
They just go flying down the fucking track.
So you don't really see it.
You see him hit the wall and then they continue like another quarter mile in
about two seconds.
But uh,
it is amazing.
But anyway,
so we got there and uh,
they was selling standing room tickets.
I get it.
People want to stand up,
you know,
get in there to watch the fucking thing.
So there's the level we're sitting and then there's this giant,
like,
you know,
uh,
walkway.
And then there's the next section.
All right.
And,
and so basically the people should have stood in that middle section where
you're walking to either make a left to go to the higher seats or make a right
to go down where we were at and where we were at,
there was two sections and there was like a,
uh,
in a little skinny hallway.
So these fucking assholes,
we're walking down and they was standing up there,
right.
And,
uh,
you know,
all they had was his volunteer teenage kids,
sitting there chewing gum,
not stopping him.
So it got to the point after a couple of races and who's kidding who a couple of
fucking mint juleps that people start going,
what the fuck?
But everybody's,
there is plot in automating still Kentucky.
Hi,
y'all doing,
I fucking hate your guts,
but I'm going to smile on your face.
You know what I'm saying?
Afterwards,
you know,
I'll fucking,
I'll stick a fucking sounds sorta farming tool and the back of your goddamn
neck,
but right now I'm going to hire you out.
They're like,
oh,
that's great.
Where are you from?
Well,
y'all from now.
I didn't get that experience in Kentucky.
They were cool as shit,
but whatever.
So finally we ended up saying something,
you know,
well,
I heads dad fucking taps this guy in the shoulder and he's like,
excuse me sir,
you know we paid to sit here.
You guys are standing up here.
I don't know what happened.
All I know is it started getting heated and I saw what Jay Jay got his fire
from.
So now you know law I hadn't version right there.
So I got to step in.
Granted,
this is the funny thing.
I got to step and dress like fucking Colonel Sanders,
right?
Or at the very least that I played banjo and a dixieland band.
I got on a fucking bow tie with the Goddamn,
you know,
my dad owned a plantation hat and I come in,
I didn't even come in.
I never got out of my seat.
I just start John at this guy.
I yelled,
I got buddy,
I paid to sit in this seat and I'm staring at the back of your head.
So he looks at me,
he goes,
what'd you say?
I said,
I paid to sit in this seat and I'm staring at the back of their head,
your head.
And he goes,
Oh yeah,
who do you look to view?
I go,
I don't like it.
That's why we're having this conversation.
Right.
And quickly I realized that he wasn't gonna throw a punch and a punch of the
dirt and I'm not going to throw a punch,
right?
I'm not gonna I'm just gonna fucking punched.
It's like a street hockey game and like fucking seventh grade.
Right.
So with John back and forths,
right.
And His fucking,
you know is broad saying something that I don't listen to her.
I can't hear that voice.
It's too fucking high up in the strategy.
Hey shut up lady.
So I said,
hey.
He goes,
what are you getting involved fucker?
Cause you're yelling at a 77 year old.
I said,
80 year old man.
I rounded up though.
Yell at an 80 year old man.
He goes,
well I wasn't yelling at him.
You're old man.
I go,
really?
That wasn't you that look like you two seconds ago doing that,
you know,
whatever.
And then the fucker woman,
you know,
he was,
that 80 oh man verbally attacked him.
Every fucking Douche,
you know,
verbally attacked him.
He's fucking 80.
What's he gonna do?
You know what I mean?
Although you've got to watch out for an 80 year old,
you know,
the very least maybe fought in Korea.
He could,
you know,
hand to hand combat.
You don't know what flashback could come back.
Next thing you know,
all right,
he's using his fucking racing form is a band that you could have some problems.
So of course me,
you know,
everybody's dressed all dapper and everything that I feel like a fucking asshole
afterwards,
everything's settled down in this,
this guy who,
who wasn't involved in the fight but was also standing up with his fucking
girlfriend and he had his hand,
not on our ass,
like under it.
And she kept moving it like,
can you stop?
Like tap on the back of my pussy with the middle of your finger,
please.
Um,
he actually looks over at me and he goes,
hey bill,
big fan.
It felt like such an asshole.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
I'm not just this fucking asshole anymore yelling at the game.
They're like,
oh yeah,
Bill Burr was a fucking asshole.
Yeah.
Ah,
it's fucking hilarious.
So then I felt all self conscious,
like is it going to end up on Youtube?
And that,
that I gave a shit about what I said it was that I was dressed like a fucking,
you know,
like I had a chicken franchise.
That's the thing I was worried about.
So anyways,
so that happens but a,
so basically we kind of did that and we kind of scared a lot of people away and
uh,
then I was Kinda,
you know,
afterwards sobering up,
cause I was still like,
you know,
I got to stay sober cause I got to watch game seven of the clippers and the
spurs and then I got to watch the pack.
Manny Pacquiao fight,
right.
Uh,
Mayweather Pacquiao fight,
right.
So anyways,
um,
I'm starting to sober up and I just started thinking like,
Oh man,
you know,
I shouldn't have fucking done that.
We both share to handle that situation better.
They should have been some,
excuse me if you don't mind,
and shit like that.
And I was thinking about it.
And then somebody finally did was just talking to me about the Derby.
Uh,
this lady,
she goes,
who's kidding,
who?
This is just a really well dressed shit show.
And I laughed because I was kind of sitting there fighting the feeling that is
fancy as this was as legendary as all this is,
this event.
At the end the day you're just kind of going to the track,
you know what I mean?
This is really,
we're just betting on the dogs,
whatever their horses,
you know.
But anyways,
um,
so what have we start betting races and of course I'm losing,
I'm losing the fucking track has been open for over 140 fucking years.
Hundred 41 runnings of that race.
Okay.
You don't stay open by fucking paying out people.
So,
you know,
I'm losing it.
I'm losing and uh,
I find just ass.
Fuck it.
I'll just bet on the derby race,
a lot of people don't know this.
The races start at 10 30 and they run them on the dirt track and there's a grass
track,
a little short track.
Um,
they just,
you know,
they'll run like six horses and a if you front,
it was funny as if you're on the other side of the track,
you can't even see the goddamn race.
You just got to watch it on TV,
which once again is sitting there fucking getting sunburn.
Right.
Like it came to this country in a raft 20 minutes ago hoping to get your fucking
Schumann writes,
Tony Montana reference.
Um,
so anyways,
well,
you know,
I just let all those ones go and um,
I want,
I bet the Derby race and uh,
I,
I just picked three favorites just trying to,
when somebody picks three favorites,
bet them across the board,
two of them came in.
Um,
and I think I will,
what did I do?
I think I lost like 25 bucks on the day.
I was down like 50 or 60 bucks and then the end I won like 30 something.
Yeah,
something like that.
But whatever.
It was a fucking awesome time.
I would definitely do it again.
I would say if you go to the Derby race,
uh,
that's actually,
that's a great thing to bring your fucking lady too,
because it's a sporting event.
You get to gamble,
right?
Your dress up.
She dresses up.
They liked dressing up,
right?
They look,
they liked the fucking horses.
Right?
Who doesn't like animals?
You know,
doesn't like animals.
Fucking animals.
Animals don't like animals,
right?
They don't self-loathing how much,
you know,
they're always talking about,
how,
what fucking animals that human beings act like.
What about the animals?
The reference,
you know?
Yeah.
You don't goes on in those woods,
in those jungles.
You know what goes on murder every fucking day.
Every God damn day throughout their fucking murdering people.
That's how they get their food.
You know,
if they murder one another,
I mean,
my,
my actually presenting the southern argument,
basically a supporting hunting.
Alright,
tell you what man,
if we didn't shoot him,
they just fucking eat each other.
So what support,
oh,
hungry too,
motherfucker.
What am I supposed to do?
Eight you might suppose to a you,
um,
oh,
one of the great heckles I ever got.
I owe so many apology in Evansville,
Indiana.
Um,
the fun thing about when people text during your show is like,
they know I always have the,
the crowd,
like I can see the first few rows or whatever,
but then it just kind of goes black.
So if somebody starts texting their whole face lights up when they're up there
so you can see it.
So I always freak people out of being in the middle of my act and I'll just see
light like 40 rows up and I'll just point right at him and I go texting,
you know,
and I do this little rift about the person dying a thumb cancer cause they can't
put the phone down.
Right.
So,
uh,
so whatever,
I'm in the middle of my show in Evansville and having a great fucking time.
It's the last night at the tour.
Uh,
you know,
we're going to go fuck,
I still have explain why I'm in Columbus,
Indiana.
Um,
I'll explain that a little bit,
right?
So I'm going to get wine in it down and get towards the end of my act and this
person's,
I see this person's face light up,
40 fucking rose up and I go texting,
can I start doing my little riff about thump cancer?
And um,
the guy ends up going,
yells out here after I finished it,
my whole long soliloquy about this person texting,
right?
And he goes,
uh,
he just yells out,
I was taking your picture.
You fucking Dick.
Oh my God.
Tagging your she fucking deck.
And uh,
I forget what I said to him,
but I was wrong.
It's like,
oh,
are you just,
and I go,
well,
you're not supposed to.
I'm going to hang out after the show.
You could do it.
Then I kind of where my way out of instead of being like,
oh,
you know what sir,
I was wrong.
I thought you were texting.
You were actually taking my picture of meaning.
You obviously we're having a good time with the show.
I was in the wrong,
I owe you an apology.
I'm sorry.
Instead I just said,
well,
you know,
you're not supposed to.
And that was like two,
two days ago.
And I just keep thinking in that,
that's been making me laugh for two days.
You know,
like when somebody just says something that just strikes you as funny,
like for two days it just keeps popping in your head,
you know what I mean?
And people think you're weird because you just burst out laughing out of
nowhere.
I've been doing that for two days.
I just went over to a waffle house.
I'm on the road,
cut me some slack,
right?
And I fucking go over there and in the middle I'm of sitting at the counter,
you know,
it's like elbow to elbow cause it's a Sunday here when I'm recording this,
um,
and I'm sitting next to this fucking guy and I to know where I,
you know,
I ain't know what I was doing.
I think I already ordered my stupid dinner,
my breakfast and night that's just heard this guys voice taking your picture.
You fucking Dick.
I just burst out laughing.
I kind of weirded out the guy next to me like why is this guy laughing?
Is he laughing at me as if fault can problem meal.
What?
Um,
so I apologize to that guy.
You were right.
I was wrong.
And then also I want to thank you for probably,
you know,
I don't think you're sitting around still laughing at my act.
You've making me laugh for 48 hours.
I'm sure you weren't laughing at my act after I trashed you for texting.
You took,
took it really personally.
Take your picture.
You fucking Dick.
Um,
that was great.
Don't do that in Alabama.
Don't say that in Alabama.
Pegging your Peci fucking deck.
And then my other favorite one was,
uh,
was in mobile.
I was doing some bit about something dumb that I did.
I said,
you can't believe that.
Why the fuck would I do that and hear this guy go fucking dumb ass.
Needless to say,
oh,
freckles had a great time.
Um,
I didn't even talk about Louisville,
Kentucky,
man.
We had,
oh shit.
So glad I didn't forget.
Oh,
let me,
let me do the Columbus thing.
Fucking add kicking in here.
Um,
how I ended up in Columbus,
Indiana is basically because all the hotels anywhere near Louisville are sold
out.
Um,
and we laid,
I mean,
I got the tickets and I waited till the last second to get a fucking room.
So we had like a 75 mile round trip drive and uh,
you know,
we all kicked in for a car service,
it wasn't that bad at the end of the day.
And,
uh,
it was great.
Door to door service so we could get all Likud.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
one of the coolest things ever.
Okay.
So we're going to Lexington,
Kentucky,
and as I mentioned,
slashed,
threatened that I was possibly considering when I was in Lexington,
Kentucky wearing my Kentucky Derby outfit on stage.
And uh,
which was basically a seersucker suit with a pink and baby blue bow tie with
silly Canadiens fan fucking socks to match.
I owe the apology to the ABS fan too.
I liked silly sox who knew a Bruins fed,
I got to admit,
silly sucks.
Have Fun.
And you know who likes some,
the fucking lady.
Um,
oh,
look at those.
Those are cute.
Had I known back when I was a single man,
I'll tell you right now,
if you're in a dry spell right now and you're not fucking getting pussy,
I'm telling you,
sorry to be graphic ladies.
Fucking go get yourself some silly socks and just stick your foot on something
that's a little higher than your other foot and you'll show it off and they'll
come walking up to you.
They'll strike it up.
Women cannot resist a fashion statement.
I'm telling you,
there's something about,
not all of them,
but I'm sounding to something about it now.
I understand those Frenchies and why they had those fucking menage a trois was,
it's not cause they're,
they're more schooled in the language of love.
It's cells fucking sucks,
which is smart,
right?
You get,
I'm looking down at your ankles because you don't have deodorant,
you know,
fucking up.
Ah,
Jesus built what is wrong with you?
Oh fuck you.
You fill an hour every fucking week
anyways.
Oh,
okay.
I'll tell you the Lexington,
uh,
story,
right after these messages here,
and I don't have my advertising yet so much to drop these.
And so if it sounds different,
that's why.
So let's take a moment right now to listen to bill burr in the future.
Struggle his way through the copy of some advertising for this week.
Oh,
Sherry's
berries.
Everybody swears Lowe's speak louder than words.
Mother's Day is this weekend.
It is officially last minute mile.
The fog is not sure how to put your thanks into words.
This mother's Day is mother's Day.
Where's Larry speaks louder than words,
freshly drip dip berries with decorative swizzles.
This mother's Day,
you know what to say in your heart.
Here is how to say it out loud.
Show your mom,
your lover with a gift from Sherry's berries.
For my listeners,
only Sherry's berries is offering giant,
freshly dipped strawberries starting at 1999 or over 40% savings.
And for my listeners,
you can double the barriers for just $10 more,
but you have to use my code B u.
R.
Barry's dipped in white milk and dark chocolaty goodness.
Talk with chocolate chips,
nuts and decorative swizzle.
Choose from Barry's cake,
truffles,
Brownie pops.
So Jesus pretzels and more.
You just need my burr when you water giant,
fresh,
juicy,
delicious.
Tell a personal story.
I don't have one.
Here's the only way to get this amazing deal.
Freshly dipped strawberry starting in 1999 over a 40% saving.
This is,
this offer is only for my listeners only when you were in a Mike Code.
Berbee you are our visit Barry's,
B e r r I e s.com.
Click on the microphone on the top right hand corner and typing burpee URL.
Go to Barry's dot com.
Click on the microphone and enter my code Burr.
Um,
Mandy's Mandy's.
No more sweaty balls.
Boop,
boop,
boop.
Me undies.
Me Mandy's.
Um,
it's good if you're gonna sprawl.
Spread your fucking sweaty legs.
Put on the son to wear and it dries out your balls.
I don't know what you want for me.
It's fucking me undies.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
90%.
That's the fucking percent of your life.
Sorry guys.
I just got off a plane and I had a couple of fucking cocktails.
90% that's the percentage of your life that you're in your underwear and you're
running to where it gets old fast.
You know that feeling of putting on old saggy underwear,
you need to know that feeling of great fitting underwear that is two times
softer than cotton.
Cotton.
You need to know about me undies,
me undies,
no more sweaty balls or clams.
Even if you're a fucking transsexual and he got all the goods,
none of it will be sweaty.
Yeah,
there you go.
Bruce Jenner,
put this shit on your mother fucker.
We on base.
It's the most comfortable underwear you will ever wear and it's insane how good
they make your balls,
your Dick and possibly have a JJ fill.
They make you feel to feel great.
They fit perfectly in a write up on you and they literally pull moisture
away from your skin so you stay,
stay cool.
I have mine on right now and I'm floating.
Half of that has to do with the fucking cocktails.
Got bumped up to first class.
They're,
uh,
they have cool,
he cool style's cool.
Styles.
Me Ed,
for both men and women and all look gray.
Check out the photos yourself.
Me undies,
dog calm.
This quality would typically retail for two times me on these price according to
me undies.
No retail.
Many middlemen means more savings for you.
Oh yeah.
Here I'll make it easy.
Golden me undies.
Calm Slash Bar and get 20% off your first order and free shipping.
Save even more.
When you buy a pack of them,
they guarantee you gotta be happy with them or your first pair is free.
All right,
last one in this little chunk here.
shave club,
everybody you have heard me talking about dollar shave club.com.
The company that delivers amazing races for a few bucks.
I know a razor that costs a few bucks.
Delivering a great shave seems too good to be true,
right?
But you really have to try the razors,
the dollar shave club.com razors.
Give me the most amazing shape I've had in years for the price.
Don't pay triple the price.
When you get a fence,
when you get a fantastic shave,
I get the hiccups delivered,
but just a couple of dollars.
Let me tell you something.
You don't have to be a fucking idiot to keep over paying.
I'm a semi known person and I'm constantly getting my picture taken by some
fucking animal outside of a bar and I'm on TV shows and high definition.
I can't be seen with nicks and cuts all over my face.
I have to shave with a high quality razors.
Don't be fooled by the price.
These razors are legit,
too legit to legitimate quick.
Come on now and you'll never go back.
Plus they also got Doctor Car Bzz Shave.
Okay?
It's phenomenal.
If you're still using old fashioned shave foam,
you're a fucking loser and I feel bad for you.
Drive dollar shave club.com/burp you are our tickets started today to get
started.
You wish you would start it sooner.
That's dollar shave club.
Dot.
Yeah.
Slash bar dollar shave club.com/burr oh yeah,
I do.
I shut this off
and I'm back.
I'm back and it's fucking yesterday or maybe earlier today,
depending on whenever I get to fucking advertising.
Um,
anyways,
let's get back to,
uh,
oh,
this is a good way for me to not to fucking get off track here is to not read
advertising.
Just plow through this shit.
Um,
so I'll actually come back out of the advertising and give you the Lexington
story.
So he goes,
so I'm sitting there,
I'm getting ready for the show and I'm ironing my regular shirt and everything
and I'm thinking I should wear the Kentucky Derby outfit.
Then it took,
you know,
we'll do know like it,
it looks stupid and it was just like,
yeah,
don't be a pussy.
Put the fucking thing on.
So I put the whole thing on right.
And I'm standing backstage and I'm waiting to go on.
Um,
after versing law had killed it,
law heads hosting.
So he's about ready to bring me up.
And for the first time since I can remember,
I was actually a little nervous just walking out to do a regular show,
you know,
um,
if it's a fucking special or something like that,
you always get the butterflies.
Um,
and I was actually nervous,
so he introduced,
please welcome bill burrs.
So I come walking out and everybody's clapping and as they're clapping,
they're taking in what the fuck I'm wearing.
Right.
And uh,
they went fucking nuts.
They all stood up.
It was one I got to tell you,
I got to thank people like to think that it's,
that's the coolest round of applause I ever gotten my life.
I've never heard a crowd cheer like that.
It was a different thing.
It wasn't,
that was funny or I relate to that.
That was a,
I can't explain it like it was,
it was,
it made the fucking tour really made the tour.
And then it was funny.
Now I'm standing there,
I got this outfit on and then it dies down and I go into my act.
And that just became even funnier.
Like,
oh,
he's just going to do is act,
dress like,
like he saw competing with Popeye's chicken here.
And um,
I toughed it out for a good 10 minutes before I finally had to take the hat off.
I'm like,
you guys,
I got to tell you this,
this seemed like a great idea in 90 seconds ago,
but this fucking thing is hot as hell under these lights.
So I ended up taking off the hat.
But,
uh,
anyways,
we,
um,
we ended up hanging out in Lexington,
Kentucky and it was,
uh,
it was just ridiculously polite people.
We were riding on the campus of the Kentucky wildcats and um,
I mean it wasn't just me even a law ahead Versie we're both just really blown
away at how great the people were in Kentucky.
You know,
I'm just really,
really just nice,
polite,
smart people.
We were right there on the fucking campus or whatever.
What are you shy?
We weren't smart and intelligent.
You fucking Dick in Evansville.
I'm just saying,
you know,
it was a different vibe.
Each one had a different vibe like I liked and everyone was shitting on
Evansville saying what a shit hole it was.
And uh,
I dunno,
I just have a different perspective living in a state that is running out of
water,
you know,
that is overly populated living in a city that's actually a desert for for some
reason it doesn't look like it cause we steal the water and everybody freaking
the fuck out.
Like captain Kirk,
they're actually having the balls to say that Seattle has too much water and
it's like,
Oh really?
Oh did nature fucked that up?
Did God put the water in the wrong place?
Shat knee Om Shanti Om Bill Jetty.
Oh Billy Shat.
Um,
it's like no,
we've been stealing the water.
At some point the check was going to hit the table.
Right.
It's time to pay up.
Who knows what's going to happen.
Do you realize I just fucking put it in one of the great bathrooms of all time
in Los Angeles and it might not have a drop coming out of the spicket.
Whose fault is that?
I knew it was a desert.
You know,
you got to know when to hold them,
know when not to build a bathroom.
Especially when you live in a desert debt,
steal some water.
Don't act like a victim even though you're a captain of a spaceship.
That was long fucking time ago and that space ship wasn't real.
I'm sorry.
Anyways,
um,
so,
so we go to the Derby.
The derby ends.
Now we're driving back,
you know,
everybody's starting to nod off or whatever and uh,
we fucking get back here to Columbia,
Indiana and we're all excited because we're going to go watch the,
uh,
Mayweather Pacquiao fight that we're gonna Watch game seven and then went to me
where the package,
Oh fuck.
Oh by the way,
I was wrong about the,
uh,
my Redwings pick.
Congratulations to the Tampa Bay lightening for closing out that series.
And then I also said that the spurs were going to beat the clippers.
I said the spurs once the clippers lost game two,
I was like,
that fucking series is over.
It's the clippers.
They don't have an enemy.
The spurs know how to win.
It's the first round they're going to fucking get past some shows.
You what the fuck?
I know.
Once again,
it shows you what the fuck I know.
Which also begs the question,
why the fuck you still listening to this?
Um,
we ended up going into,
uh,
the buffalo wild wings up the street.
Oh yeah.
The buffalo wild wings.
And uh,
it turns out they don't have to fight with like,
what do you mean you don't have the fight?
It's the biggest fucking fight in the last 10 goddamn years in boxing.
How do you not have to fight
Mr Wilde links?
Can I call you a buffalo?
A Buffy?
Why don't you have the fucking fight,
right.
Well,
we walk in there and within two seconds we realize why they don't have the fight
because it's an absolute shit show.
We walked into that fucking place,
the buffalo wild wings.
Um,
and they had game seven up on the big screen.
They had two big screens set up on the big screen.
They have game seven of the spurs and the clippers and next to it they have
another big screen.
And on that they have some replay of a golf tournament.
And for whatever fucking reason,
when we walked in,
the volume was up on the golf tournament to like spinal tap 11 I've never heard
golf commentary that loud in my life.
And meanwhile the Spurs,
it was already the third quarter.
It was just to start coming out of this coming out of the half.
It was like 54 52 some crazy like that.
So I guess it was,
you know,
quarter in mid,
mid third quarter,
right.
And was sitting there while I had immediately beside himself,
led,
used to manage a fucking restaurant.
So we always walked in and we get them going.
We go,
Jay,
could you manage this verse?
He always says,
Hey Jay,
could you manage this place?
And he goes like,
you came here to get right and I'll tell you right now,
she'd be fired.
And he just starts firing half the staff.
It's just this fucking running joke.
And we asked them about this place.
She said,
well,
how would you manage this place?
He said,
I boarded up and shut it down.
Called the fucking regional manager and say,
we got to start over again.
So we say to the waitress,
uh,
can we put the a game seven basketball fan on or are these you guys really into
golf here?
And she kind of laughs in.
Yeah,
I don't know why the volumes up on that either.
So they switch it over to the game
and we were watching the game.
It's still beside ourselves that a buffalo wild wings for as much as you watch
their commercials,
like this is the place to go to watch the game.
Everybody with their tall fucking slender hoary looking glasses,
drinking the blue moon with the orange in it,
right?
Having the best fucking time ever watching the game tell a little petty lies to
their friends and their wives and all this shit because it's so great.
Isn't that also the one where you get to hit pause so you can just make this
amazing experience continue even longer?
I'll tell you right now,
man,
our experience at the buffalo wild wings,
Applebee's could talk shit.
The buffalo wild wings.
And you know,
when you go to an Applebee's to watch a game,
you watch that on a square kitchen TV.
All right?
That's stuck up next to some fake brick,
you know,
as they bring you in with one of those hot skillet,
that's some shit that they think is fancy.
All right.
I was poor people.
No,
we eat at Applebee's is,
is,
has progressed beyond the seventh grade.
And that's a fact.
That's actually one of the requirements to manage an Applebee's.
Okay.
Your grades have to take a major dip and the seventh grade lost all hope by the
10th grade.
All right.
Anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
So anyway,
so I'm sitting there going like,
wow,
that's really fucked up that the wild winks of Buffalo.
Um,
why is dementia chicken wild?
so anyways,
I actually went to look up,
uh,
you know,
I don't know,
I was just reading on the,
uh,
the pack yet.
Oh wait,
wait,
wait.
What the fuck am I talking about?
So the fucking clippers ended up eating the spurs and one of the Great Games
I've seen in basketball in a while and great series,
God knows your reason why I watched it because I was hanging out with Verdesian
lie have missed all the hockeys.
You can tell.
I know Tampa Bay's up,
uh,
one game to none on the habs.
I know the ranges are up to nothing on the capitals.
I think that ducks won their first game and I don't know what's going on with
Chicago.
Uh,
we'll bill,
you could have looked it up for the podcast and you know what you could do,
you can go fuck yourself.
You could do it till four,
maybe if I fuck this up and makes you feel good because you get to correct me on
Twitter.
Um,
anyway,
so,
um,
I ended up,
we came back,
I crash inverse.
He texted me like two hours later and says,
I guess the,
uh,
the Mayweather Pacquiao fight was a shit show.
It was boring as shit and blah,
blah.
And people were basically saying,
and I'm so,
I was kind of looking it up today to see what the deal was and you know,
basically boxing purist or at this point,
people who actually watch boxing,
we're saying that it was a great fight and that may,
whether,
once again pull it up,
pull it on an absolute clinic and if you actually knew your ass from a fucking
hole in the ground when it came to boxing,
you would actually have been able to see that.
And he wouldn't have been pissed moaning and complaining that it was boring.
You know,
which I understand.
Cause I know when I watched UFC,
which I don't know a lot about,
but I watch it on TV and Rogan's always describing,
wow,
the guy's going for a Comoro,
he's going for this and going for that,
the crowd after a while starts to boo when they're laying on the ground cause
they think it's boring.
But you know,
a defense of those fans when you sit in 200 rows up,
he can't see what he's going for.
All right.
It looks like two people cuddling.
Um,
but they can't quite get comfortable.
There were a new couple,
you know what I mean?
That trying to see how the two bodies fit together.
So,
um,
anyways,
so I just started reading about the fight to see what happens.
Um,
I actually had my wife pay for the fight.
I'm going to watch it tonight.
Um,
cause at the very least when I watched and it makes me want to get in shape,
um,
by,
which is a great thing to do.
By the way,
if you hate skipping rope type of fucking championship fight,
that goes to distance stay.
You Go,
all right.
Then all you do is you press play.
And when they fight,
you skip rope.
When they sit down,
you sit down and then he kept going.
He tried to see how many rounds you can go.
All right.
And as they get tired,
you get tired and you feel like you're actually a fighter.
And then the end of it,
you realize you just some jerk off in his,
in his underwear skipping rope.
Right.
And it hurts when it hits your toes.
Um,
all right,
so here's how the paper,
I've actually looked up some shit.
Here's how the pay per view worked out.
And I own,
I own another apology to the wild wings of Buffalo.
God knows if you ever go out to buffalo,
you've got to watch out for the,
for the not to domesticate it.
Chicken,
it's the wild chicken.
All right,
those fuckers,
we'll take you out,
man.
They'll jump right on the hood of your car and they'll peck through your
windshield and there's nothing you can do.
One of them goes for the electrical.
So you fucking,
you can't start your car right?
And it's,
it's over.
It's like one of those a Alfred Hitchcock movies check.
It's um,
here's other pay per view worked for,
uh,
for bars or anybody basically showing it at a commercial level that was going to
charge for the many,
uh,
the Pacquiao and Mayweather fight bars.
Venues had to pay 25 times their,
their fire code,
fire code being the maximum amount of people that can be live establishment.
Um,
so it's not a fire hazard.
So you had to pay 25 times basically being sold out.
So basically out of the gate,
if the bar charts $25 a head,
they needed to sell out the bar just to break even on what they paid for the
fight.
This is why boxing is so fucking dumb.
Okay?
You got a sport that he's starting to lose to the UFC or not starting to.
It has been,
and this is what the fuck they do when they got this great fight to maybe bring
the casual fan back.
You know,
this is what they do.
So if you had a bar that was actually worked out,
the numbers 250 capacity,
right?
That's the fire code.
That would cost you $6,250 to get the fight.
Then if you charge 30 bucks ahead,
you try to make five ahead.
If you sold out,
you'd make 1250 he got to spend 66,250 bucks to make 1,250 bucks.
And that's if you fucking sold out.
All right?
And there's nothing stopping the guy across the street from also having the
fight or from people at home going,
hey,
why don't we have fucking,
you know,
five people watch it.
It'll cost us 20 bucks ahead.
So you're competing with all of that.
There's nothing exclusive about this.
This isn't like,
hey,
you know,
fucking,
uh,
whatever,
Justin beaver,
fuck you.
We sells tickets is performing at my venue in my venue alone tonight.
Now he's across the street.
He's fucking everywhere,
right?
So Boston boxing basically said to these bars that were taken all the money.
Um,
we've taken all the money from your customers to watch the fight.
Okay?
And then you take the booze and the food.
It was essentially like a door deal that was based on the bar taking
responsibility to sell out their own venue.
How dumb is that?
Like now,
not to mention these two guys should have fought five to seven years ago when
they were in their prime.
I'm not saying they're not great fighters,
not the great fighters of all fucking time.
I'm just saying they should have fought like in the two thousands.
It's 2015 they finally fucking fighting.
Um,
I just think,
I don't know,
boxing is just,
it's just a really poorly run fucking sport.
And the fact that fighters can dodge one another for so long.
I think that that's why
you don't have those great fighting divisions anymore.
Like when I was growing up,
okay,
seventies and eighties when I was a kid and then get into my teenage years,
boxing was unbelievable.
All right.
And what happened with each decade was they would just,
you know,
the planets aligned and there'd be this ridiculous of talent in one division.
And then that was the division you wanted to watch.
And then the,
like in the,
in the 70s it was the heavyweight division.
And then in the 80s it was the middle weight division.
And meanwhile there was all these other divisions that had like,
Alexis are Gwalia and boom,
boom,
man sceney and all these,
these superstars.
But I think a guy like,
you know,
like nowadays,
then it became the dump.
But back then it was just the wolves at the WBA WBF was all,
it was then.
It was the WBF.
And the WBA the IBF and that would be like the NFL split into fucking three
football leagues.
It,
you know,
in each one of them had a super bowl champion if fucked the whole thing up.
And then all of a sudden the UFC comes along.
You got everybody under the one umbrella.
And even some of the other groups like UFC of don't exactly what the NFL and the
NBA did.
Like when the,
the Aba or the,
uh,
the AFL came out,
the NFL just absorbed that league,
the NBA absorbed the Aba.
The League was,
you know,
that upstart league was then over and then they had just had a monopoly.
So then the best football team or the best basketball team has to play the
second best one.
And then that's the champion fucking,
uh,
boxing.
It hasn't been like that forever.
So I think that that's why,
okay.
I think Mayweather's suffers because of that.
Even though he wouldn't probably wouldn't be undefeated because he wasn't
getting the kid who have Mayweather fought back in that division when Hagler
Hearns,
libray,
Leonard Duran,
if all of those guys had losses because they all had to fucking fight each
other.
And nowadays it's like,
you know,
fucking you watch Mayweather and Pacquiao for fucking seven years before they
finally fucking fight.
I know a lot of you guys as a bill,
you don't know shit about fighting.
I admit that.
Okay.
But if you want to survive as a fucking league or as a division or whatever the
fuck your Sportage,
you got to get the asshole like me to buy the fight.
The casual fan who says dumb shit and the person who actually watches it sits
there and rolls there.
I know the feeling.
I go to super bowl parties.
Right.
I just don't understand why the fuck they doing that because boxing is such an
unbelievable sport.
Um,
the only thing that does bug me about it is I am a hockey fan and I hate when
they talk about the fighting,
how they got to get the fighting on a hockey.
It's really,
but really you got to get the fighting had a hockey,
but,
but you don't have to get the fighting at a boxing,
you know what I mean?
That's all they do is punch each other in the fucking head to the point that
they end up with Parkinson's disease.
Okay.
Fucking hockey.
They occasionally fight.
It sits a little spice.
It's a little fucking flavor to the game.
Well,
he's fucking,
people can't handle it with don't fucking watch.
Ah,
chases bill.
You just did the sporting version of Uniloc at lunch.
Get the fuck out of the country.
Taking your picture,
your fucking Dick.
Doug.
You picked fucking Dick.
Um,
the more exaggerated,
the more,
the more just keeps giving.
Oh,
it's the joke that just keeps giving.
All right,
let's do a,
let's do some more questions here,
but I'm having said all that,
who the fuck wouldn't want to be in the shape of Mayweather?
A fucking packing out.
Good Lord.
The fucking dedication alone,
that just,
that takes,
forget about the fact that you have to push down the sickening,
sickening,
nauseated feeling that there,
there was a worldcast class athlete training somewhere in the universe to just
beat the living shit out of you,
I'm asked is fucking unreal.
You know,
mean if you're going to get to a fight,
don't you want to just,
just to happen.
Like,
you know,
you just sit in there and all of a sudden you're fucking yelling at somebody at
the Kentucky Derby,
then it just fucking happens.
But if you have to sit there and think about it and train for it and know that
somebody else is going to do it,
that's just the level of balls that are,
I obviously the old freckled wonder here.
I,
I can't,
I can't relate to that.
Um,
all right,
so here we are.
This is the money money podcast,
everybody.
And uh,
I do this once a week and once a week.
I got the just checking in on your podcast on Thursday,
the Tuesday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
Um,
that's the one I just sort of,
that's a newer one.
I just do like 30 minutes and then I play some classic hits from,
uh,
from years gone by.
In another world where podcasting was young,
it was innocent and it was unified unlike boxing.
Um,
if you'd like me to talk about something or whatever,
if you want to suggest some topics,
the way to do it for the Thursday one is you tweet@abillatthemlmpodcast.com,
which with the Hashtag t a m m p all capitals,
tango,
Alpha,
Mike,
Papa,
sorry.
Um,
and for the Monday morning podcast,
if you'd like me to read your emails,
your questions or whatever,
um,
just send it to,
Oh,
I'm such a dope bill@thempodcast.com is the email for Mondays?
I can't,
I've never gotten this fucking right.
All right,
fuck everything that I just said.
Fuck it.
Dhg Ish.
Um,
all right.
For the Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast just before Friday.
All right.
Hashtag t a m m p and the Twitter account is at the Mlm podcast.
All right,
good Lord.
Now.
If you want to email me for the Monday morning podcast,
it's bill at the Mlm,
podcast.com.
Jay's has Christ bill that was all written right in front of me and I still
fucked it up.
Um,
for the Thursday one,
you can tweet articles,
videos,
questions.
Um,
I guess you know what?
You don't need to tweet at the MLM podcast.
You can just hashtag Jesus is the third version.
You can just tag
t a m m p.
Oh fuck that.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I mean,
that was just,
if anybody has a business school and you want to teach you about what not to do
on advertising,
why don't you just play that clip?
All right.
Under the slide caption shit show.
Pro Flowers.
Everybody.
Mother's Day is only x days away.
I guess I was supposed to do the math.
Uh,
who in your life would win the world's best mom award?
It's a good problem to have when it's a tie.
Three way tie.
I don't get that.
Which of these relate to your life personally?
Your own mom,
your wife,
your mother in law,
your grandmother,
your sister,
your cohost.
Talk about why they are deserving or what do you do,
what you,
what is wrong with you?
You think I wouldn't do that on my own?
Pro Flowers.
My mother is the best you think I can't give her pro flowers with the top of the
line face.
I need you to cue me with,
with your copy.
Appreciating all moms.
This mother's Day doesn't have to be stressful.
Relax.
You got this.
I know,
I got it.
So stop telling me what to say.
Pro Flowers proflowers this offering radio listeners 100 blooms with a free
glass vase for just 1999 or make her day extra special and upgrade to a premium
vase and add chocolates for just 999 more.
Go to pro flowers,
flowers.com today and use my code Berg Gurr pro flowers has all you need for
mother's Day,
for all the moms in your life.
All in one place.
All at one time.
Pro Flowers are guaranteed to be fresh and beautiful for at least seven days
here.
It's the only way to get 100 blooms with a free glass vase for just 1999 visit
proflowers.com click the blue microphone in the top right hand corner and typing
burn,
B u,
R,
r,
that's proflowers.com click on the microphone and type in Var orders today.
This offer expires Friday at midnight.
All right,
two more and I can pass out.
Okay.
Draft kings,
everybody.
Have you heard the news?
draftkings.com crown in its first ever fantasy golf millionaire right there.
Could you be next?
Draft Kings is America's favorite one week fantasy golf site where you can win
huge prizes every week during every tournament.
Just heard just head the draftkings.com before tee off on Thursday.
Pick six.
Golf is stay under the salary cap and when cash,
whether you're an avid fan of the game or just ready to try a new fantasy sport.
Draft kings let you experience golf like never before by playing to win a life
changing pay day.
These are the biggest one week fantasy golf contest anyway,
and it's only at draft kings and they got hundreds of thousands of fantasy
sports fans just like you have discovered.
Draft kings.com now it's your turn.
We're Amanda to pick your players,
but for tee off on Thursday morning to seriously cash in on Sunday night.
Hurry to draft kings.com now and use the Promo code defense to play for free and
the hundred thousand dollar a fantasy golf contest this Thursday right there.
First place takes home 10 grand entrance defense for free entry now had
draftkings.com draftking stock comp.
Once again,
that is draft kings dot cow.
All right,
legal zoom,
everybody.
The last one,
five things you can count on when using legal zone for your business.
Ready?
Number one,
reliability.
More than a million people have already trusted legal zoom to help start their
business.
If you're looking to incorporate,
to incorporate form an LLC or nonprofit,
get a DBA and more legal zoom can help you get started the correct way,
the right way,
the best way,
no.
But to experience they've been helping business owners with legal challenges for
more than a decade,
you can count on legal.
So for all the details,
number three,
helpful God damn support.
They have the right people on hand to answer your questions all based in the
United States.
So they speak English number for legal advice since they're not a law firm,
legal zone built a network of independent attorneys available in most states,
they can give advice or the best way to get started.
Plus provide contract review and other useful services to help your business
move as smoothly as he see this spread butter.
And finally,
number five,
no surprises,
everybody.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency with the upfront pricing and customer
views and they have a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
What more do you need?
Make the smart choice for your business@legalzoom.com today.
And don't forget to enter burpee.
You borrow@thecheckouttosaveevenmorelegalzoom.com Promo Code [inaudible] B.
U.
R.
Thank you.
And God bless.
And this has been the advertising for this week back to me back in the future
where I was a little more Sopa.
Okay.
Evansville,
here's a something.
Greetings Bill.
I just want to take a moment to thank bill for an incredible show in Evansville,
Indiana.
Thank you very much.
I'm actually upset
when we rode into town.
I didn't get to go to the,
uh,
the cross side,
grasshopper family restaurant.
I mean it was the fucking name like that.
How do I not go in there and eat amongst those water bugs?
I'm kidding.
I'm sure it's a nice clean,
friendly place.
Uh,
he said my face still hurts from laughing also.
I was wondering what were the names of the two opening acts?
Uh,
they were both great.
Well that would have been Paul Versey,
v I,
R,
Z,
I and Jason Law head spelt like law.
Break the law and head.
I'll kick you in the fucking head.
Why can't it be something nice?
Okay.
I will fix the cowlick on top of your head gently
as they stare at your eyes.
Um,
stare at your eyes.
Look romantically.
Oh fuck though.
Forget it.
All right.
Thursday podcast.
Um,
a pill on the old clips.
Uh,
you talked about an urban legend.
Oh yeah,
I was talking about all those urban legends about,
you remember pop rocks dope.
They was just a kid and he,
he ate a whole box.
He sucked down a whole package of pop rocks in his fucking stomach exploded.
And there was always the one about dude,
there was a kid who he put in,
he put an Mat,
which is an eighth of a stick of dynamite,
I believe.
We always thought it was a quarter stick.
I think it's an eighth.
Stuck it in the back of some kid's pocket litter in a blue,
half the kid's ass off.
So this guy says I'm willing to mid eighties.
My brother,
my stepbrother did just that.
He had to get skin grafted from his thigh to his ass.
It's no urban legend from New Jersey.
Oh,
maybe that's where it started.
They always say there's a little bit of truth in all of that shit.
Is that what they say?
That is what they say to Billy.
Holy Shit.
The Thursday podcast is the best thing you could've done.
You are a genius.
I'm not a genius.
Andrew came up with it.
Uh,
the old clips are hilarious.
I love dropping it on the middle of an old school podcast catching you in a
random moot.
Yeah,
that is the thing.
Cause my vibe on this Thursday then it connects with whatever the fuck I was
talking about on some Monday in like 2009 or 10 or something.
So I guess that would be a weird little mash up.
As the kids say,
I'm,
this person said I listen to a lot of podcasts.
Over time some of them changed.
The hosts get egos and the vibe is different.
I love how you're 10 times bigger than you were when you,
I'll look at this whole fucking ball rubbing thing here.
Did I write this?
I'm 10 times bigger than I was everybody when I started the podcast,
but I still act the same.
All freckles is down to her.
What,
when you're a balding,
redheaded male,
you really don't have the opportunity to take your shirt off in VIP.
Do you?
Huh?
Spinning around your head.
I swear to God,
if I had pigment I would be a much,
oh my God,
I the Ego.
I would fucking have you kidding me.
If I had pigment,
a full head of hair,
you guys wouldn't even know me.
Um,
the day that they actually come up with a pill cause I would never do that
fucking,
you know,
taking hair from the back of your fucking head,
putting on,
I would never do that,
but I'm not,
I'm not fucking doing that.
Numb it up my head.
It's just like,
all right dude.
Phil,
why don't you just admit that it's over?
All right.
Fucking buzz it down.
Grow some sort of facial hair,
you know,
or just shave your face and let people look like,
just make them look at a rapidly approaching 50 year old adult baby.
How mad.
Don't do this by the way,
cause you'll get in trouble.
But how fucking funny and how mad would the person get if you walked up to a
fucking guy who had his head clean shaved and his face.
He didn't have any facial hair.
Right.
And he's in his forties or whatever.
You just walked up to him.
He's sitting in a bar,
minding his own business and you walked up when you're underneath his genuine
oh,
Gucci,
Boo Boo.
Like how far did you get away before that person?
I think I would know somebody touching you would make you mad.
Other than that a man think I'd laugh.
Um,
but don't do that.
Everybody.
Okay.
The world is a,
is a bad enough place you really don't need,
you know,
you don't,
do you really need a bar fight?
Think about that people.
At what point in you in your life do you sit there and be like,
you know,
what would be a good asset to my life right now?
Both spears spiritually,
personally and legally.
A nice knock down drag out bar fight.
Although that would be funny though if that happened.
And then you guys actually decided to work it out on like judge Judy.
You know,
when she comes out there,
I'll fucking extra angry for the fucking,
uh,
you know,
for the TV cameras.
And you went out there and though you know the ball guys guy go,
ah,
you know,
it's my mail business and this might come up,
hey,
put his finger Charlie bit my finger and it hurt.
He put it on,
I don't know,
Amit cheek and anatomy chin.
And what did he say at that time?
Uh,
he said,
uh,
coachee killed [inaudible]
right.
And I didn't like it.
I don't know like it to be English or whatever the fuck I was just trying to do.
Right.
There's no robbery.
I got to get back to fucking peaky blinders when I get back on two episodes and
I'm going to watch every fucking episode I can before I go to all,
to all my shows in Boston there.
Um,
all right,
what else was there?
Uh,
thanks for the last man.
My days go by much quicker.
No worries.
Everybody look at that.
The Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
The just checking in on your podcast to make it fucking quicker is really look
at people are liking it.
Check it out if you can.
Um,
oh shit.
All right.
I gotta read another advertising came before I get into the rest of these.
Uh,
once again,
this is bill burr in the future.
Desperately trying to read out loud
my Jesus.
We're back in the past.
They're actually,
when you're listening to all of this,
it's all in the past,
isn't it?
I don't know.
All right.
Booing at the draft from a lady.
Hey Bill.
My mother in law is a huge sports fan and she insisted on watching the draft.
I have never seen the draft before and I was really shocked at the rude behavior
of the spectators.
Well,
you've obviously never gone to a sporting event.
I was going to a sporting event is watching a bunch of people that probably
can't catch a ball or maybe they could,
but now they're just old and out of shape.
Just,
you know,
just trash and people that can do what they,
they could never do.
That's what it is.
Um,
anyways.
Is that how it normally goes down or is it because it was held in Chicago as a
Wisconsinite?
I would've thought it was a Wisconsin or a Wisconsinite.
Uh,
that lives in a tourist destination for those damn fib.
He's
fucking idiot bastards.
Oh,
fucking Illinois bastards.
I can't close a,
as we call them in door con door county,
I instantly blame Chicago for all the [inaudible].
Are My instincts to correct or is it always like that?
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
No,
you're instincts are not correct.
And as far as how Wisconsinites view people from Chicago,
you know,
that's just standard behavior standards.
Human behavior.
You don't like your neighbor,
you don't like your neighbor.
This town,
his rivals with the town next to it.
This state doesn't like the state next to it.
This country doesn't like the country next to it.
You need,
you just keep making it bigger and bigger.
This continent doesn't like this continent.
You can go right up.
Just basically familiarity breeds contempt and it takes an unbelievable level of
maturity for you to be sitting up there and cheese land to look down at mustache
city and see the good in it.
You know,
especially when they're coming up there de vacation and in your area,
you're not going to like it.
When I lived in New York City,
I fucking hated walking through time square bunch of fucking families with their
kids going to the fucking m and m store.
You know,
they actually made you wish that it was still peep shows,
which was disgusting.
It was fucking Gross Times Square back in the day was gross.
And now they've gone the other way,
which just a,
you know,
it's a lot of big people in Jean shorts,
plodding through traffic,
not knowing where they're going.
And uh,
there's nothing like a giant,
a giant group of people likes to do more than to just stop and stand in the
middle of the sidewalk looking around,
waiting for someone to make a fucking decision,
you know,
a bunch of followers.
All right.
Walking into the Hershey Kiss store,
you know,
buying some fucking New York tee shirt that has fucking,
you buy the New York tee shirt with a picture of John Lennon on it wearing the
New York tee shirt.
You want to do that shit.
Yeah.
You fucking hate that stuff.
So no,
I don't think it has to do with that.
I mean,
obviously you know,
Philly's known for Boeing,
uh,
New York City's known for bullying Boston's north of dope.
You know,
it say,
yeah,
you know,
it's a shit show and people also fly in for the draft if you can believe that
they fly in for the draft.
I will never understand that.
I already did a bit about it on my last special,
but I will never understand that.
It's like going down to the DMV when you don't have to.
Yeah.
Someone's going to take the test for you.
All you gotta do is just see how they did the next day as you're reading and
fucking English muffin.
There's no fucking reason to go down there.
Um,
yeah,
I haven't even looked.
I haven't even stopped to even look to see who my team took.
Um,
okay.
And I don't give a shit.
I mean I care,
I want them to do well,
but like I'll wait till the football season to see how they do.
But I guess those are the people that get into it a lot more younger ones don't
want to.
Those are the people actually know the names of like the GMS and the higher ups.
And like I,
I just don't have fucking time to get into it to that level.
You know what I mean?
I have too many other things that waste my time.
Um,
so no,
I wouldn't blame it on Chicago.
I love Chicago.
I love Wisconsin.
I think you guys are all great standing from the outside.
I don't know what your fucking problem is.
The same way I look at the Middle East.
What is the fucking problem over there?
One of your guys,
if everybody just became atheists in the Middle East,
you know,
and they find something else.
I don't like it.
Shoes.
It's blowing them up.
Um,
game.
Show a bill.
If you could be on any game show from any time period.
I want a great question.
What would it be?
I'm a huge,
I'm back in the day.
It was a big game show fan when I was growing up during this summer,
we didn't have a pool,
right?
We lived on a busy street.
We used to watch the prices,
right?
Every day Ben Happen,
uh,
data,
data.
Is that the one?
Well,
the thinking music on the match gains,
boom,
Bam,
Bam.
What the fucking why Wah pedal was big in the 70s.
All right.
Um,
let's see.
I picture you on the prices,
right?
Good call.
God knows you're not cut out for jeopardy.
Fuck you.
Or wheel of fortune.
Kidding.
You're a smart bass.
And on that,
on a wheel of fortune,
dude,
you can have everything but the vows and I still can't get it.
Um,
I'm really bad at that.
Like you see,
I'm not good at reading out loud.
I'm not good at reading in general.
Everything gets all jumbled up.
You know,
my eyes travel faster than my brain can process it.
It's an shit show.
Uh,
he goes,
I see you teaching old ladies how to put in demonstrating what,
how to pot and demonstrating the wheel going around.
Oh yeah.
I thought you meant as a contestant.
You're talking about hosting.
Yeah.
All right.
Or a demonstrating the wheel going around one full rotation and not to mention
the kisses on the cheek from all the fucking ladies.
And instead of Barker's beauties,
it'd be birds.
Beauties.
Your thoughts are,
if I can host
any show,
um,
I kind of liked the family feud,
but this too,
you got to talk to too many people.
I'd rather just deal with the head of both families.
Like a mob thing.
Like let's have a little fucking sit down.
All right.
You know,
you seem like a reasonable person,
but you know that shit show behind you.
I really don't want to get involved in.
So why don't you ask them what the fuck they think and then you say it.
How about that?
All right,
so I would not last long on that.
A wheel of fortune.
MMM.
I could actually,
I wouldn't mind host in that one.
The sound of the wheel is annoying to me
and I don't like when they fucking lose it to her and they go,
Ooh,
that we'll get to me after awhile.
Cause I would think like that would be the soundtrack to my career at that
point.
Although Vanna white still,
they're still looking on,
you know,
she threw me a glance with those beautiful fucking eyes.
I that could be a fun one.
Uh,
prices,
right.
I mean that's the iconic one.
I mean that's the fucking patriots.
That's the Yankees.
As much as I hate to say the Canadians and game shows,
right.
It is fucking is actually to be fair,
it's the green bay packers because they wanted the most NFL titles of Superbowls
combined.
I would have to say that.
So,
uh,
yeah,
prices,
right.
I,
you know,
I like about the prices,
right.
Is you're not confined to just one game.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like wheel of fortune is the one game,
the spinning the wheel,
spinning the wheel,
spinning the wheel.
Fucking family feud.
I asked you a name,
a sound of a Fart,
and you said surveys such,
you know,
whatever.
I think you're just doing the same thing.
Fucking over and over again.
Right,
but the price is right.
There's all those different games,
all the different games.
And then you know,
you got to halftime like a sporting event.
I think you nailed it,
dude.
Remember card sharks,
all of it higher.
All of it lower.
It's fucking stupid.
It's really hard.
You know if he can come up with a good game show,
one of the most brilliant ones ever was,
who wants to be a millionaire?
That's such a fucking simple idea.
I can't believe I didn't fucking thing to do that.
Sure.
It's helping be hosting this podcast right now.
Be Drinking myself to death somewhere on a fucking,
yeah.
I don't know what,
none of the islands be getting sick.
Dayas stroke.
I don't know where the fuck I'd be,
but I wouldn't be sitting here right now.
Who wants to be a millionaire?
Hey,
who doesn't?
I mean right there,
fucking show sells itself.
I don't want me to do,
I'm going to come up with a game show for like the porno network called who
wants a blow job?
I don't.
Right.
There you go.
There's your show.
Then you just ask like fucking questions about,
uh,
you know,
whatever sex brim job.
Is that your final answer?
Financial Room Job Doodoo do.
You are correct.
Um,
all right,
let's move on to the next one.
Mary woman takes man's leg.
Okay.
Hey Bill,
I'm,
I am 19 years old.
Oh,
by the way,
I'm really happy that it.
Fuck a woman finally wrote in here.
Hey Bill,
I am 19 years old just graduating high school and not going and going to enlist
in the U S Marine Corps.
Uh,
just a little about me in parentheses.
I have been listening to your podcast for about a year now and I find you
hilarious.
Anyways,
I came across this video and apparently this lady steel,
this steel's this guy's leg when he goes to sleep and has been holding it for
ransom because this guy cheated on her.
I just wanted to get your take on this,
sent you the best and discussing the ladies.
Thanks for all the labs and go fuck yourself.
So wait a minute,
this guy's got a fake leg,
obviously.
No bill,
he's got a real one and she sought it off and fucking,
I dunno,
what do they do then?
They stick you stump in a fire.
That's how they used to do it in the,
uh,
the cowboy movies to cauterize or whatever that fucking word is.
Clarify your fucking artery.
I Dunno.
Stop the bleeding.
Does that even work or is that just some Hollywood shit?
I have no fucking idea.
I don't pretend to be a doctor or even look like one.
Um,
what do I think about that?
Well,
he fucked around.
Hell hath no fury.
Well,
how long has she had the leg?
You know what I would do?
I just buy another one.
I light up my car.
I'd buy another one and I would fucking,
you know,
walk awkwardly over to our house and I would just be like,
really?
You know,
what do I think about that?
I think as she should give it back.
I understand why she fucking did it,
but,
um,
that's that bullshit that women can get away with where they can get away with
destruction of property in that type of shit.
Like,
you know,
they can throw all your shit out the fucking window,
light it on fire and do all this type of crap.
And the cops show up just laughing.
You know,
I'd been there.
I fucked around and my girl,
I got a dick too,
buddy.
This is what happens every once in a while.
They like to shit on fire.
She's like a fucking Allah cat and a fucking year.
Um,
what do I think about it?
I think it's fucking hilarious.
The obviously,
uh,
you know,
you fucked around.
What are you going to do but get mad about that.
You got it.
I would think that if I had a fake leg
and I was fucking around,
uh,
I would be wearing that thing to bed.
You know what I mean?
Or at least I'd have a backup light.
I think in general,
once you have a backup leg,
I mean,
even people who can't see got a backup pair of glasses,
right?
She'd have another leg.
You know what do you have a fucking egg?
You know,
you know his cell phone charges.
I have.
I fucking lose those things all the time and I know what people would note with
willy.
One legger thinking,
dude,
you have any idea how expensive they are now?
I got both of my legs,
but I can tell you this,
I cut back on the drinking to have a spare.
You know what I mean?
I'd be still watching a square TV before I would buy a flat screen.
Okay?
I wouldn't buy a flat screen TV until I had an extra fucking leg that that's a
debt's a fucking guarantee.
Okay?
You can take that to the Goddamn Bank.
All right?
But you know,
let's get to the real story here.
Let's talk about this fucking Mack Daddy.
He only has one God damn leg and he's still fucking slaying it.
You know?
I bet that got her fucking goat.
The fact that,
you know,
this guy's got one leg and she's sitting there,
pat yourself on the back of what a good person she is.
That she's,
you know,
that she can see.
I don't care about appendages.
I care.
I care about what's in here now,
what's hanging off your pelvis except for that your Dick,
you know.
Um,
but who knows?
Maybe Bruce Jenner doesn't want his leave.
He,
you test.
Maybe you could buy his.
Sure.
It's a little bit older than you are,
but you know,
I don't need to cath is your coq one.
I'm not trying to belittle you.
I am not Joe put words in my mouth.
Um,
yeah,
I,
you know,
that's fucking hilarious.
I can't come into work today.
Why?
Well,
I fucked around on my girlfriend.
She took my fake leg.
Oh,
you're going to hear is the boss
on the other side?
Fuck you.
What are you going to do buddy?
Hot Down here and kick my ass.
You're gonna fall down.
Um,
anyways.
All right,
so I'm sure we're going to hear from the people with one fucking leg out there.
You know,
quit your bitching.
Okay?
Can always be worse.
All right?
It can always be fucking worse.
You know what I mean?
For every person out there with one leg,
all right?
There's someone else in a loveless marriage.
Okay?
And that's even worse every fucking day.
Waking up next to that person,
man,
or a woman and not feeling a fucking thing.
As they look into your eyes and they hand you that car,
and on Valentine's Day,
you might as well be talking to a chest of drawers.
Um,
all right.
Wow.
That was dark.
All right.
Gathering and protesting verse riding.
Bill,
I sympathize with the black community through all of this.
Oh God,
this sounds like it's going to go off the rails.
Hey,
I have a black friend,
but said that.
Um,
all right.
It's ridiculous.
Uh,
some cops,
not all of them can be total assholes with pent up anger and absolutely no
control over their violent actions.
And it's no excuse.
He shouldn't have to do that job unless you're a saint who also knows how to
kick ass.
It's fucking hilarious.
You want a superhero at that point.
Where do you stand on the protests slash?
Riots?
Where's the line?
Obviously destroying someone's business is ridiculous and doesn't promote social
change.
But I also sometimes
he just,
he misses a word,
but I also sometimes think,
I think he was supposed to,
you got to crack a few eggs,
please use the next five to 10 minutes to solve this social problem.
Hilarious.
Um,
I dunno when I watched that you're just watching the results of a,
you know,
what happened a long time ago.
It's the fallout of all of that.
Um,
the genius of a saying that one race was better than another race.
So you could fuck over both races,
but you adjusted how you were doing it and you get to keep all the money at the
top,
right?
Like you're basically sticking a dick and everybody's ass,
but you go balls deep with one people and another people,
you're only halfway in and then you get,
so then the genius of that is you got someone with half a dick in their ass
actually feeling lucky because it's not balls deep.
Right.
And just the fallout of that is what you're watching.
So make any sense other than I can't just totally blame super rich people on
this.
So the controlling people throughout the centuries.
But I will say that,
uh,
just generally speaking,
even at horseshoe with a lady in Wisconsin,
just looking for the bad in Chicago,
people in blaming all of the bullshit behavior on a
draft day for the city of Chicago.
Um,
I just think unfortunately,
the inherent nature of people is to,
uh,
be selfish,
conch,
to be fearful,
to want more,
to be worried about tomorrow and,
uh,
to want to be a,
I dunno,
feel a little better than the other person may look at me at the Derby right now
where I was sitting.
I was two steps above where those people were standing.
And when I stood up,
I could still see the fucking race,
but I was like,
I am a sinner.
You are a standard.
You are less than me.
And next thing you know,
I'm yelling at this person,
like I built the whole fucking area.
Right?
Um,
I just think it's in our nature to not get along.
I hate to say that because it's the easiest fucking thing to do because it
doesn't take any effort
getting annoyed by somebody as effortless.
Actually having empathy and seeing where the fuck they are coming from or maybe
thinking about how you should say something and respecting somebody.
It just takes a lot of fucking effort,
you know?
And you know when the heat of the moment that usually doesn't happen and a,
there you go.
I overly simplified the whole fucking thing,
but I think it's a,
I dunno,
I've been through Baltimore,
I've been through Detroit,
parts of Cleveland,
parts of Buffalo,
that rust belt and stuff.
Then you know,
parts of the south.
Now some of the places I went through,
you can't believe how people are living in this country and it's just fucking
wrong.
It's wrong.
And then we're over there allegedly trying to rescue people in other countries,
which is the dumbest shit ever.
It isn't.
We're just taking their natural resources and make it,
I mean,
we are,
I don't want get into all of that shit,
but I just don't think that this country is sitting there looking at other
countries going,
God damn it.
Fuck yeah,
they're just not free.
We got to do something about,
this is bullshit.
I don't,
but I don't buy into any of it.
It's a,
yeah.
And this is another thing too.
I have no fucking idea how to turn that around.
No fucking way.
I turned it around on a societal level.
I can't tell though on an individual level,
uh,
you can totally turn around your life without a fucking doubt.
You just have to fucking,
yeah,
you just can't.
You got to become unstoppable.
And the more down the fucking shit slide you are the morning stoppable you have
to fucking be.
And that's just the way it is.
Life isn't fucking fair.
And for as bad as you got it,
somebody got a fucking worst.
I mean there's a guy with one fucking leg who can't go to work cause he stuck
his dick into something else,
which he's fucking wired to do.
You know?
I mean that woman taken out of the guy's leg.
She's basically saying God is wrong,
you know,
but she won't get called on it.
We'll shoot.
Yeah.
Did any of that make any sense?
I actually started daydream and halfway through that,
um,
this bill burn,
this has been the Monday morning podcast.
I would like all of you to go fuck yourself and I'll talk to you next.
I'll actually taught,
I'll check in on you on Thursday,
but I'm basically going to talk to you.
I talked to you every Monday,
Thursdays.
I'm just checking in on you,
you know,
just poking my head in seeing how the fuck you doing.
But this,
this day here,
this is the real shit,
right?
And if you'd like the real shit and it is a pile of shit here.
And if you would like to,
uh,
contribute to the Monday morning podcast effortlessly,
well,
this actually takes a little bit of thought.
Next time you go to Amazon to buy something,
just click on,
go to [inaudible] dot com,
click on the podcast page and then just click on the Amazon,
a little fucking app there.
Whatever the fuck you think you call it,
the banner ad,
it'll take you right to Amazon and then buy something if you want.
And if you do,
I get a little credit for driving some traffic there was already going to go
there anyways.
They kicked me a little bit of fucking money.
Um,
they're basically whoring off the love that they think you have for me in this
podcast.
That's what they're doing.
They're trying to pile on that shit.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
I don't want to talking about,
um,
thanks to everybody sincerely for the last two weeks,
I wiped out.
I am tired,
but it was one of the great experiences that I've had in my standup career to
get to go to all these cities that I had never been to.
Um,
other than New Orleans.
I had never been to any of these other ones as far as I can remember.
And it was awesome.
The people were great,
the crowds were awesome.
And uh,
oh,
people ask me about the Billy Bible belt poster.
Do I have any leftovers?
Yes,
I do.
Yes I do.
I've got a couple hundred left.
Um,
and I just shipped them back to my house.
They're all going to be autographed.
Okay.
And uh,
they will be available for sale on my,
uh,
on my website as soon as,
as soon as I get home.
Probably take me about a week to put them up there.
Uh,
they are high quality.
I forget what size they are,
but they are a nice size.
Just look at some of the tweet Twitter pictures of them.
Um,
those will be available,
but when they're gone,
they're gone.
I'm not making any more.
I even get one.
I didn't need one.
I fucking did.
They shows.
Oh,
all right.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.